hello Internet welcome to my couch where
I gotta be honest I did not want to make
this episode no no joke I was actively
looking for excuses not to do this
episode and yet each time I shelved it
ever since the try guys drama first
started my feed has just been full of
entertainment news media making like the
worst takes possible about this
situation saying stuff that wasn't just
cringe wasn't just face palm worthy but
was just actively making me and everyone
else on the team mad because of how
ignorant and irresponsible it was so as
a YouTuber and as a business owner it
felt like I had to sit down on the couch
and set the record straight to call out
a lot of the problems that they're
having as it relates to this wider issue
so consider this my open letter to
mainstream media friends strapping
because film Theory it's getting its own
first ever serious couch Time episode I
was supposed to stay over on Game Theory
so if you've ever existed on the
internet or you're even not on the
internet you're probably familiar with
the try guys at this point Keith Zach
Eugene and Ned the four of them got
their start on BuzzFeed during its
Heyday becoming one of if not the first
format on the site with a recurring cast
of popular relatable characters and
their show was simple but effective the
guys try things no click bait there it
is all there in the name they put
themselves out of their comfort zones to
wear women's high heels or wear women's
Halloween costumes or wear women's
underwear you know what come to think of
it there was a lot of wearing women's
sexy things in the early days but there
was also plenty of other videos out
there like watching them learn to dance
ballet or race dune buggies or play
rocket League admittedly not all of them
were bangers but still it was fun to
watch These Guys these Fish Out of Water
experiences as these complete noobs were
learning all about the weird wacky
interesting dangerous things in the
world around them eventually they
decided to break off from BuzzFeed
because let's be honest everyone made
that decision and they decided to create
their own production company second try
collectively we decided it was just time
to try something else and that involves
this new production company out of Ned's
old house a little weird without a
corporate Overlord suddenly they were
free to make and do whatever they wanted
with their brand can now be truly
unabashedly holy ourselves there's no
holding back because it's ours we own
that light and you know what that's
exactly what happened they took their
brand and they made it into everything
that they wanted it to be live shows
merch podcasts spin-off shows books
documentaries interviews with important
people like Dr fauci they even got
themselves a show on Food Network which
then brings us to recent times and the
drama about a month ago the try guys had
to fire one of their founding members
Ned the one with the house from those
clips earlier the reason for this well
it came out that he had been having a
long-term workplace affair with a try
guys producer and production manager for
Productions like their documentary and
their spin-off show food babies put a
pin in that we're gonna come back to it
after the firing the remaining try guy
with an eye get it because there were
three of them left it's a lame joke
other people have made it but they made
it to me first so I get to claim it
anyway they made a video about the
situation to their 8 million subscribers
multiple fans alerted us that they had
seen Ned and an employee engaging in
public romantic Behavior Ned confirmed
the reports and thus began a three-week
process of engaging with employment
lawyers corporate lawyers HR PR and more
we were acutely aware of just how
contrary this was the values of the
company we've built and those of
everyone who works here so on Friday
September 16th the three of us signed
written consent approving the removal of
Ned as a manager and an employee so now
that you're caught up with all of that
we've spent the last page of this script
talking about the history of the try
guys
throw it all away because I am here to
tell you that at the end of the day this
video is not about them it's not about
their drama this couch time talk is all
about the mainstream media and how they
covered this entire situation you see in
the aftermath of the team ousting Ned
the internet just blew up with coverage
about this situation Wall Street Journal
CNN Vanity Fair Cosmo the sun and the
coverage was fine for the most part I
mean there was a surprisingly large
amount of it but it was you know it was
okay it was neutral it stuck to the
facts of publicly made statements things
like that but then in a desperate bid
for relevance Saturday Night Live
decided to enter the chat with a sketch
that is so off the mark that it
single-handedly wanted me to make this
video so the full story is that your
friend had a side chick and you fired
him yes and we hope he is somewhere on
his back with a bullet in his brain and
belly whoa okay isn't that a bit extreme
no you have to remember Laura the side
chick was a food baby in a fit of rage I
drafted a script up but ultimately I
home down and let it pass I mean I was
worried about SNL here if I were to make
a video about every single unfunny out
of touch sketch that the air well I have
infinite content but a brilliant Channel
idea anyway I let it go and about a week
passed and everything was fine until yet
another article was published about this
whole situation this time from The New
York Times and again it missed the
entire point of the situation using
lines like uh this uh quote right here
the whole thing felt a bit like a
hostage video this is in reference to
the three guys sitting on the couch
informing Their audience about the steps
that they took in removing Ned from the
channel as if there were people just off
screen with rifles and high expectations
there sort of were they were on the
other side of the camera and miles of
fiber optic cable and the try guys found
themselves in a position where however
shocked and betrayed Their audience felt
their own livelihoods depended on
appearing equally distressed appearing
it made this whole thing out to be just
a glorified performance actions done
only for show in order to appease an
audience that somehow had them
imprisoned heck the whole thing ends
with this incredible line you can
imagine Ned fomer watching the video
seeing his former friends solemnly
tamping down the freshly laid dirt all
in an effort to mollify an audience of
strangers and realizing that however
badly he may have messed up he was
finally free
oh boy okay so there is a lot to break
down there and all of it highlights
mainstream media's mishandling of both
online creators and more importantly
workplace issues like the metoo movement
so let's just start with the YouTube
stuff because that one is far less
important now I think it's no secret
here on the channel that I'm not the
biggest fan of traditional media
coverage of our industry that I've
talked about it on this channel and this
Channel and that channel and and this
channel again and is this probably why
they don't write articles about us
anymore it's probably why they don't
write articles about us anymore anyway
just take a look at exactly how SNL
decides to introduce what it is exactly
that the try guys do to their audience
the one in the world is a try guy third
BuzzFeed pranksters who try stuff like
trying fingernail polish or weird
haircuts hell they're even tried eating
bugs if you look across the wide array
of YouTuber coverage this one is always
the favorite call any type of YouTuber
prankster Jake Paul well he's a
prankster PewDiePie prankster former
NASA engineer Mark Rober well yeah he's
the glitter bomb prankster Mr Beast
obviously he's a prankster too there is
no world where what the try guys do
would be described as a prank Channel
but yet that word is a favorite of
newspaper coverage because it evokes
such a strong emotional response when
you read about pranksters pranksters
aren't people that you're meant to like
they're not someone that you root for
the whole it's just a prank bro crowd is
associated with low effort content that
monetizes people's suffering call
someone a prankster and immediately
you're sidelining them in people's minds
and someone who's mean-spirited and you
probably don't don't want to succeed and
of course it's not just enough to just
write them off as pranksters you then
have to highlight how much money they're
making off of those pranks that make
people mad and they're millionaires
oh well you readers and viewers at home
you work so hard at your job every day
making pennies but here are these
pranksters on the internet making
garbage content and getting rich off of
it isn't that unfair doesn't that make
you mad the New York Times article
actually takes a different approach
that's even worse than this instead of
calling them just Mindless pranksters
the nyt describes the try guys
backgrounds like this a group of friends
becomes a cast of characters and strip
mines lives and relationships for
content
oh if that doesn't sound flattering well
it isn't uh the Crux of the entire
article is that yeah the try guys have
people who watch them but only because
they basically sold their soul to the
internet in exchange for their Fame
except that couldn't be further from the
truth the content that's made them so
popular is just Classic Fish Out of
Water reality TV it's basically the
online equivalent of dirty jobs or wife
swap where people are put into new
uncomfortable situations and then they
have to learn to adapt you know and no
the irony that I just used Wipe Swap
here as an example in this situation
doesn't escape me but it's entirely true
they're formats like cooking without a
recipe I mean it looks a whole lot like
chopped Keith eats everything at a
restaurant well that's just the modern
day equivalent of the eating show Man Vs
Food and yeah that one video that
everyone keeps bringing up as an attempt
to embarrass them and tear them down the
one where they do the unthinkable and
try on women's underwear well that's
been a Trope of comedy in media forever
I mean there's an entire episode of the
sitcom friends that is named after that
exact plot line
you want to go yeah that'd be great let
me make sure I'm not doing anything
Tuesday
company with something like 20 employees
and they're producing reality TV content
something that both of these news
outlets should be familiar with but
either aren't or are disingenuously
refusing to acknowledge in order to prop
up a false Narrative of digital Creator
bad the article then implies that not
only are they milking their lives for
Content but they're actively
manipulating their young impressionable
and emotionally needy audience the try
guys were always bad people Ned was just
the first one to let the mask slip they
conjured a non-toxic brand of
masculinity until Fulmer flicked the
lights on exposing the fantasy its
severe mood was in part a performance
meant to reassure a world historically
anxious and distrustful audience that
they had not been LED astray for the
last eight years obviously these are
both really bad looks and pretty
intentionally meant to discredit not
just the current situation but the whole
system that holds it up YouTubers
function by fundamentally lying to their
audience Maybe because they're low life
pranksters or because they're just
manipulative of kids and remember this
is talking about the try guys the try
guys are like the Melba toast of online
content and that is not meant to be
offensive to the try guys or anything
they produce I love the stuff they
produce but if there is one thing that
Melba toast is known for it is being not
spicy so what could The New York Times
or Saturday Night Live have done well
outside of some very basic research and
being open and honest with their
audiences for one they could have
connected with the fact that both of
them are located in New York and guess
what the try guys recently performed in
New York right down the street at the
great white Way Broadway or their New
York Times best-selling authors who also
is the New York Times oh wait the paper
that's publishing this article in the
first place synergy programmatic synergy
friendos or if none of that makes sense
just say that they got a Food Network
show hey you people you don't watch the
internet but you do watch Food Network
because everyone watches Food Network
these are guys on the Food Network done
you understand who they are I'm just
saying if the goal was to bridge the gap
in understanding between YouTube and the
readership of a 170 year old publication
or a 40 plus year old comedy sketch show
they could have done it very easily they
just didn't because that was never the
goal in the first place so listen up
mainstream media come here get up right
in my face right here because I'm gonna
get real with you guys for a second this
is the hard truth playing ignorant with
the stuff that's going on online is not
the flex that you think it is whoa isn't
it funny that people care about these
random dudes called the try guys who try
things no no it isn't funny you guys get
what on Saturday Night Live these days
what like three and a half million views
an episode and that's talking about TV
numbers which we all know is kind of
like they're not really that believable
regardless guess what that random online
Keith guy he got just as many views from
eating Panera you are currently trading
short-term Jabs at the wackos on the
internet for your long-term relevance or
maybe you're only aware of online
content to the extent that you can steal
it it's a Charmin Bears parody where the
dad is disapproving of the son who's
going to college and doesn't want to do
the family business of butt wiping
anymore he wants to dance instead my
video was a Charmin Bears parody where
the dad is disapproving of the son who's
going to college he doesn't want to be a
butt wiping bear anymore and he wants to
dance instead that right there that is
Joel Haver amazing online Channel by the
way um you know what Joel I I have to
disagree with you though because I
watched the two videos side by side and
I don't think they're similar at all for
one thing your video was actually funny
oh I'm gonna get rigged over the coals
for this one I'm making no friends
because here's the thing I'm not even
all that concerned about this one yeah
sure I get really mad about how they
reported and mishandled this entire
situation around online creators but
also at this point I've come to expect
it that is just par for the course we
get no respect over here the real much
bigger issue with all of this and the
true reason I had to sit down on this
couch was because both Outlets
horrendously mishandled the core issue
that prompted Ned's removal in the first
place I'm trying to understand why this
story is such a scandal was this a fair
non-consensual no worse he committed the
heinous act of having a consensual kiss
and not telling us his friends the
entire controversy that led up to this
is framed simply as Ned Fulmer sharing a
consensual kiss and not telling his BFFs
about it and let me be real clear about
this because no media Outlet seems to
grasp this concept the try guys are not
some group of buddies they're not just
hanging out making some videos for the
laws on the weekend they are a legal and
financial set of business partners who
own and operate a very successful very
popular media company they have legal
and fiduciary responsibilities to each
other and more importantly to their
employees which in plain English for all
of you mainstream media writers who this
is just going over the heads of means
that they are obligated to put the good
of the group and the company ahead of
individuals not just because of morals
but because in a business with multiple
owners you have a legal requirement
plenty of people have affairs plenty of
people have open marriages frankly we
don't know the details of that
relationship and guess what who cares we
don't need to know Saturday Night Live
though makes it sound like severing ties
with Ned was this act of Vengeance from
jilted friends we had no choice and we
hope she is somewhere on his back with a
bullet in his brain and belly but the
truth is that workplace romances aren't
the meat cute of the office Circa 2004.
as a business owner a secret boss dates
employee relationship is inappropriate
in its power dynamics but beyond that if
you don't even want to get that far it
presents massive legal liability to
everyone working inside that building
and if you're an owner who knows about
it and chooses not to do anything about
it guess what you're liable too if that
relationship ends badly it is a wrongful
termination lawsuit at best and a sexual
misconduct lawsuit at worst now you
don't need to know the details of those
two things but the point is either one
can easily bankrupt the company and put
dozens of innocent employees out of a
job so instead as a responsible business
owner you just cut your losses and you
put that one employee that one offending
employee Ned out of a job it's math not
Intrigue it's ethical and it's good
business the Saturday Night Live skit
though not only tries to awkwardly
diminish this relationship as a kiss
between co-workers as opposed to what it
really was a long-term relationship
between boss and employee it then goes
on to do what I am most offended by to
frame Eugene Zach and Keith as angry
betrayed friends as opposed to what they
really were angry betrayed business
owners trying to do the right thing the
New York Times article actually takes it
further than that saying that the try
guys have to be so miserable they have
to continue lying to their fans and
maintaining this facade but Ned he must
be happy that he escaped he got to drop
the mask and he survives to live on
another day and you see that is the wild
thing that I just can't wrap my head
around with all of this coverage you
know who received no blame in either of
these examples Ned Palmer in both of
these pieces it's the remaining three
guys that are left on the couch that
look like they're in the wrong they're
the over dramatic Divas mad and ousting
their friend out of pettiness no no
mention of Legally endangering the
company no references to making your
co-founders implicit accomplices no talk
about predatory behavior in the
workplace or how the entertainment
industry has this massive problem with
sexual misconduct no mention about how
Ned built his professional brand all
about being a loyal family man and
undercut that brand in a way that
jeopardized the livelihood of literally
everyone in the business around around
him I mean all of those would be very
valid and important takeaways from the
situation why not mention any of that
why would you try to vilify the people
sitting on the couch trying to do the
right thing well it's because if Outlets
like SNL decided to talk about that it
might draw attention to the fact that
Saturday night Live's been accused of
having a bit of a sexist culture against
women throughout the 90s and 2000s not
much of a joke when it's about you SNL
for instance one woman allegedly was
summoned to a producer's office and
shown inappropriate pictures of him
other interns have allegedly been
brought to after after parties where you
know you just use your imagination
what's going on over there these are
serious accusations and this is
literally just the tip of the iceberg in
some cases lawsuits have also added an
SNL Creator Lauren Michaels and former
cast members like Tracy Jordan and Jimmy
Fallon into the mix alleging that they
were aware of this misconduct and
enabled it in One Way or Another
Saturday Night Live has had these issues
for decades and has never once had its
owners or creators made public addresses
to the audience to take some sort of
accountability instead you get sketches
like this you can have sex with women at
work without losing your job by
following a few Simple Rules be handsome
be attractive and don't be unattractive
talk about things that haven't aged too
well it's no wonder they're making fun
of the guys on the couch here because if
they didn't they'd have to acknowledge
that their own history has a lot more
Scandal and a lot less Integrity than a
bunch of YouTube pranksters and you see
that is the thing that has gotten me so
frustrated about all this that is the
thing that's got me to sit on the couch
to make this episode everyone keeps
pointing to the video that the try guys
made on the couch as if it was some sort
of an overreaction some sort of over
dramatization it wasn't if anything that
sort of thing should be the new Norm it
represents a generation of media
companies who are trying to do better to
be better who aren't willing to sweep
scandal under the rug business owners
who stay transparent and take real
meaningful actions when someone steps
out of the line no matter how high in
the company they might be you shouldn't
be making fun of Keith Zach and Eugene
you should be following their example at
the end of the day this isn't some weird
fluke in the news cycle or some weird
children's Obsession this is the new
generation of entertainment media
companies putting their money where
their mouth is who are able to swallow
their pride own up to their mistakes or
their employees mistakes and then sit on
the couch for some serious conversations
when they have to and from this couch
gotta say that seems like we're moving
in the right direction but hey that's
just a theory a film Theory and cuts